[Music]
oh hey Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size 4 rest huh how you so big look at
the big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
down put up on a six sorry about the
mess hold
on oh hey b hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy look to God we're
going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop collaborate and listen back
with a
Newen 5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in
a car can someone unlock the car
please call in
everybody I want him
found what was that little pothole
Maxi's been up the whole time by the
way wish
that before I met you mom I was a covert
assassin I escaped at life and now they
found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us look at you playing the family man
I'm not playing this my
life hey I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait
[Music]
wait new
record hi Barbie hi Ken
[Music]
hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Ken hi Ken
[Music]
radi I thought I might stay over tonight
why cuz we're girlfriend boyfriend to do
what I'm actually not
sure
[Music]
okay ladies let's do
[Applause]
[Music]
this what are you doing here I'm coming
with
you did you bring your roller blades I
literally go nowhere without help
them oh looks like this beach was a
little too much Beach for you Ken if I
wasn't severely injured I would beat you
off right now Ken I'll Beach off with
you any day Ken anyone who wants to
beach him off has to beach me off first
I will Beach both of you off at the same
time be both nobody's going to beach
anyone
[Music]
off
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for
anuma L what now in fact in Lumpa land I
am regarded as something of a Whopper
they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won see I'm
something of a magician prepare to be
amazed
taper inventor may I present Willy
Walker's wild and wonderful wishy-washy
WKA Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
o he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send w a
message do not sell chocolate in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head I love a bonk on the
head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
bullies give them the old one
too I got idea where do we start making
chocolate of
course run away every good thing in this
world started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world I'm not in premium
of me good night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke you quite
viciously with a cocktail
[Music]
stick
hey head of the wedding of my sister yes
I am so where's your fiance wait is this
him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass on
your break wow you are a child it's a
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Creatine and smelled like insecurity
nothing small about me what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this
girl's a
[Applause]
disastrous they're going to ruin our
wedding sorry
sorry what's it going stranger what's
going on over there they dated she
crushed his heart that man does not have
a heart no way honey look who's here who
is this my ex Jonathan my parents have
been trying to get us back together he's
like a son to us maybe we should just
tell everyone we're together what it
would solve that problem for me and you
clearly want Margaret she seizure with
me she want wish she can't have there's
no way we can convince anyone we
actually like each other you know I
still think about that night we went
together shut up no I'm
serious no matter how it ended it still
pretty
[Applause]
amazing convincing enough let's do
it honey here he is oh no I'm within so
is it like we just got together or we
been sneaking around let's just be
affectionate Showtime permission to put
my left hand on your right buttock
granted it's not a magic
lamp hey little guy
God damn
it we have to kick it up a notch nice
tou
nice oh no no it's going to be when are
you ever going to learn [__] it it's
fine Titanic me are they watching are
they doing Titanic they're gone show's
over oh my
god do you have a mo or something on but
no what the [__] what the what the one
might be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what did we miss what did we miss
[__] it it's
fine stop Gary court order for asset
seizures so they're taking my car you
and radio silent on me is that what this
is about my feelings for you were so
intense that I got scared is that true
B that's my cousin Gary I swear to God
he's my cousin he's my second cousin
there's something seriously wrong with
you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car I'm going to lose my house you think
I chose
it look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his
shell before College in exchange we'll
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
bet that means sex my husband the code
breaker we've just been so worried about
our son he's going to Princeton in the
fall no I've heard of it you we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls he doesn't drink
so when you say date him do you mean
date him or date him yes date him date
him hard I'll date his brains out he
volunteers at the animal shelter hi mind
if I touch your wiener what your
dog how about I give you a ride home um
this isn't the way to my house it's a
shortcut you're my hostage what you got
down there something for
me why you tried kidnapping me you're 19
grow up
this kid is undatable have a drink
together he'll have a Long Island IC
tea this is the worst ice tea I've ever
had don't know what to do I just know my
mom would have wanted me to save the
house probably just nervous you losing
them up we can do skinny dipping what
about sharks none here jellyfish not
this season it's really the lack of Life
CH me s in here right now okay I'm just
a bit of a romantic he's actually really
sweet the best part about getting older
is not having to care what people think
I'm an adult now I can make my own
decisions that's good you want to save
it save
it come on you're getting out of here
you don't belong here touch me get away
from her
[Music]
stay MADD you can't outrun the car I
can't lose my
license
here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
Dan what is this place we are completely
lost was your
mother that is not your mother looking
at it now we're trying to get to Jamaica
it all seems so
simp don't worry Chum's got you so
listen Chum what did you just call me
sorry I thought your name was Chum yeah
chump yeah that's my name what right so
listen Chum what did you just call me
sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
[Music]
what this isn't about migration it's
about Adventure wo wo wo wo hey
what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that dange what's
dange it's you with Lan on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and
we when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this crazy
wonderful
[Music]
Adventure you're so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm
kidding where am
I
huh go go
[Music]
[Applause]
go do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you're put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the
universe me neither but you know one
hope
right wave to Mommy cuz she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it has I'm running a business
and right now that business is getting a
journalist in an out of
palonia no it's a oneoff no no and no
who's a journalist I have resigned my
position here 20 grand says you
are welcome to
president Vega so nice to meet
you we must take a selfie um you
approve it's
great
else ow what the hell just happened your
one man's security detail happened he's
a hero I'm with the president of a
country in the middle of a coup this is
the scoop of a lifetime you got to be
alive down have the scoop of a lifetime
God you never should have come let's go
you can't just leave
[Music]
him run
run ready to go I don't know how to stop
when you start at the bottom only way to
I'm just doing my
job do you need help I get up again and
I got to win I get up again then I got
that's win what nothing you still
excited to cover a coup less and less
honestly where is
vas here is Vegas go for B hey not the
time for coaching
man oh my
God Color Me impressed Mr Petit not
Petit at
all tell me you got that
[Music]
run honey maybe we should just haul it a
night you go ahead I got to finish these
centerpieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like
Pilates we got you a gift it's your
Something Borrowed brings you good luck
except for uncle Greg when have
decapitated on that forklift but that's
not the knife's fault oh someone just
left that in the
bathroom you invited your
ex looks like he's leading a porn Safari
oops he forgot to button his shirt all
the way up is it time for
[Music]
dinner you look so much better than the
rest of us I think the left boob is
slightly lower than the right boob
something doesn't feel
right
[Applause]
Pirates outside and they took everybody
hostage here's the plan I'll trop him in
the net spray him in the eyes it won't
work too many
steps see that's why you have a plan
with one
step not once did I wonder if I'd be
walking h
Through the Jungle what with a live
grenade a grenade sir sir give me the
grenade sir I got it I got it you got it
I got it you got it I got it
[Music]
it are you dead we're going to face
this that dress is growing on me wanted
something less
traditional nobodys with my
family don't let go don't you let
[Music]
go
should
[Music]
Lou stop shoting your
sister Carol thank you for the cake
knife I freaking love this cake
knife
H you guys must be new to town right new
to town but not new to the country we
just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you would mind if your
your daughter played with our daughter
Audrey say hi you want to play slide
mhm slides off limits to Ching
chongs [__]
you do you want to be best friends look
at me look at me look at me now guess
who's going back to the motherland it's
a big deal going to your birth country
we used to talk about it all the time
when we're little remember Grand
Adventure to find your birth mother so
proud of
you white people call my translator in
Beijing Audrey I got
[Music]
[Laughter]
you cat lives there now your famous
college roommate you ready to lose to a
celebrity deadi ey is coming by the way
deadi ey your cousin hey Audrey oh hi
where did that come
from you know I think I get it I called
the adoption agency and she lives in h
jene okay will you guys come with me
[__] yes [__] I love a grand
adventure oh hi so nice to see an
American what do you do for work it's
the cops are doing a back check [__] oh
my God you're a drug
dealer you're drug dealers now [__]
what the [__] is that a condom we can't
get caught with drugs in China we'll get
jailed for life crazy got to BL crazy
I should never come to China people are
always thinking that I have this perfect
life I don't belong anywhere if you do
not know where you come from how do you
know who you
are we could still find her our
passports are in my suitcase that got
stolen you know who can bypass the
airport security K-Pop Stars everyone
remember their names sassy cutie Lisa
Lisa to I don't believe these girls are
s girls show them um what are we
supposed to show you're a fan of card B
right yeah is she
hear there's some whes in this house
there's some
wh in this czy honey you good did you
get the cook bags out yeah but only
seven and I think I put in eight just
push pull I mean twist it it's not a
buet it's my
[__] I told you I'm on
vacation while I'm on vacation I'm going
just float come here Mr
Parker Marcus and Emily Parker you have
failed to notify your airline that you
are registered sex offenders
[Laughter]
what what the hell is wrong with
you look at us all together again we
just wanted to give you guys a real
honeymoon just found this crawling under
our table he's crawl cing it's your
first time it's a prodigy it's
amazing what are they doing letting us
in a place that's nice how the hell did
you get us in here you didn't tell them
they going to be long G by the time I
get into my work thing you must be Mr
Parker apologies for the change in
schedule Mr y has invited you for drinks
all of you guys I need you to be really
cool can you do that for
[Music]
[Applause]
me I love
you
look who you're talking to when have we
ever not been
cool dad literally just released from St
Clinton I got you the best wedding
present what why does this coke not
taste Coke because it's your mom noted
your mom it's really kind of beautiful
if you think about it this how picture
things going at all the school marus is
cool we floating right we
floating let me down get your hands I'm
about wife get ever since he showed up
he turned this relaxing family vacation
in total chaos who does
that we have been through
ham why we just go back I knew it
chicken there's only one thing left to
do
sir I've never seen that much water come
off a person before did I throw up a lot
your butthole threw up
[Music]
bud
I sent you to the royal wedding with
simple
instructions don't cause an
international
incident how's it going you've done some
pretty stupid things in your day but
this Takes the
[Music]
Cake Henry shoved me an urge I currently
share what I need is some good
oldfashioned damage
control the White House and the palace
are going to release a joint
you've got to be joking you can hate
Prince Henry all you want my NDA is
bigger than yours I want you to know
that you're wearing lifts know that too
sweetheart you better act like the
Sunshine's out of his ass and you have a
vitamin D deficiency have you thought of
what you might say to convince the world
that we're actually friends I love
hanging out with this
guy we never have to see each other
again you're expected at my New Year's
[Music]
party did I do something wrong do you
ever wonder who you'd be if you were an
anonymous person in the world I have no
idea what you're talking about as thick
as you
[Music]
get love your majesty it's your Royal
Highness dear Alex I miss
you that's what I really was good
morning we are in a hotel crawling with
reporters if anyone sees you leave this
hotel I will brexit your head from your
body your Royal Highness you need to
figure out if you feel forever about him
do you love him what difference would it
make if I did I
want Prince Henry belongs to
Britain we can figure out a way to love
each other on our own terms it's like
there's a rope attached to my chest and
it keeps pulling me towards
you hopefully we'll get through tonight
without any more
scandals the night is young ma that's
what it
was
[Music]
all right let's a
go oh my
okay not sure if you know who I am but
I'm about to rule the world
wow uh yay but there's one problem
there's a human has a mustache just like
you do you think I know every human
being with a mustache wearing an
identical outfit with a hat with a
letter of his first name on it because I
don't Bowser is
coming together
we are going to stop that monster how
look at us we're
adorable I got this no
problem
yes come on Mario our big adventure
begins now ah get it off get it off get
it
off there's a huge Universe out
there with a lot of
galaxies they're all counting on us
Mario
no
pressure
[Music]
wooo I'd like to report a crime that
hasn't happened yet have you seen the
movie Back to the Future basically I'm
living that movie right now which is how
I know there's going to be a murder
tonight hate time travel movies they
never make any
sense happy Halloween how about we all
stay in and hand out Halloween candy no
Mom you know how hard this time of year
is for us your friends were murdered 35
years ago it's not 1987 anymore stay
safe honey I love
you
ini what the
[__] excuse me what year is it 1987 oh
my God I know the 80s are almost over
and I haven't even tried Coke
yet I don't know
oh my God Mom [__] off and die Jesus mom
masita
Mita time for my birthday
[__] this is a creepy ass cabin in the
middle of [__] nowhere what's the big
deal there is a murderer on the loose
and you drove us into the woods oh my
God what I forgot to bring
[Music]
vodka you have 7 and 1/2 hours into
until you're stuck here
forever I need to stop all this horror
before it
happens do the machines kill us all no
they more just rip apart the fabric of
our society via Dance videos on Tik Tok
they dance against
us come on out water's warm just so you
know I don't do [__] you pee out of
that
thing just think maybe if she did do
[__] she'd still be alive yeah let's
not make that the
[Music]
lesson 's weed sucks this is just dirt
look at all these Twigs you I could give
you a gummy this big that has 100 times
more weed than
[Music]
[Applause]
this I'm Ria KH I am going to be a stunt
woman my sister l
is the only person who believes in me
want to help me with a vid for my
Channel
please she helps me with all my training
you are going to be such a great stunt
woman that was dop but lately she's been
seeing this guy who I think is a bit of
a SMY
wanker you know it's a Tru oh my God Ria
chill out now I'm not being
dramatic but these people are
evil I found
something I C my eye on you they are not
taking her away without a
fight I will strike down you or anyone
else who tries to get in my
way how about the bikini
area Let's
Dance we need to get Lena out
[Music]
is a
fo is not going anywhere you little
[__]
rude mom what are you doing
a mys the pr nothing
changes we are going to show who these
people really
are let's decimate this
mother CRA y calling me
crazy did you see my kick of course I
buddy did it was
magical I'm pretty sure I drew blood I
sure you did
Mr Renfield
welcome I
am
the you will make a very good assistant
no he's evil we will protect you you
have the word of the most trusted
institution on Earth the Catholic
[Music]
Church Renfield you're so purpose in
life is to serve me now let's
it I's just want to normal life
again God bless you Mr Renfield oh God
bless you nun hero well but monu
Renfield let me explain I work for
Dracula Count Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me the
dark one others the Lord of death so you
bring in people to eat well I do other
stuff like what washes Cape no the Cape
is dry clean only strictly yeah I would
wear this is fly
yeah I don't think he's such a bad guy
but you're never really going to be free
until you face him I will no longer
tolerate abuse I deserve happiness let
me explain something okay you deserve
only suffering all right I will unleash
an army of death everyone you care about
will suffer because you betrayed me we
have to stop him Before
[Music]
Sunset I am
enough I deserve
happiness and I take full charge of
my
die
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is going to be my way worst it's my
least favorite part of the
[Music]
job
I can hear you being quiet
mom I um hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order it's just hard to see my little
man not being my little boy all the
time
yeah for years I've been taking care of
this little
boy
making sure he is
loved that he feels like he belongs
wherever he wants to
be he wants to go out into the world and
do great big
things not bad
kid and what I worry about most I love
you
miles is they won't look out for you
like
us
miles want to get out of here wherever
you you go from here you have to promise
to take care of that little boy for
me make sure he never forgets where he
came
[Music]
from and he never doubts that he is
loved and he never lets
anyone tell him that he doesn't belong
there you got to promise mil
I
[Music]
promise who do you think you are
really we are supposed to be the good
guys we
[Music]
are come on get your lazy ass up all
right all right I'm up already that's
what you get staying out partying all
night I'm a promoter I'm working I got
like 18,000 followers you know who got
followers Jesus take your rude ass to
work you just cursed what would Jesus
say Jesus would say shut the [__] up
this is my
house see you late as usual need to
clean this place I got all day oh e what
the
[__] that couch just flued itself whose
crib is this man Steve JS Steve Jobs is
dead fool that mean his house
died dude got Miami [__] Cleveland [__]
La [__] damn pick a city
bro oh my God we in LeBron's house
LeBron who James hey there go go you're
a one handsome [__] he got a
hologram of himself just to give him
compliments you handled the decision to
go to Miami perfectly nah that's
cap I need 10 G's by next week I got to
pay for my daughter's school le BR they
on vacation how about we throw the party
in the King's house we going invite all
the
celebrities we can make 10 times the
money we can send Destiny to preschool
College whatever tonight is our last
shot looks like we y out the th
house hi I see you there how are you
he's a white man oh [__] oh [__] we
going to jail kid hi I'm Peter is Le Ron
home um by the way black lives matter
they do I posted two squares on my
Instagram
respect get out of my way
myit this is a really bad idea I
wouldn't do something like this unless I
was
desperate [__] cracking
bro have you seen how out of control
this party is
[__] we done [__] up the
koala you good what the [__] just
happened your hairline is perfect anyone
who says otherwise is just jealous this
[Music]
guy
La lav stay still stay still now now
now let's try that again but with ninja
stars hey why do we pick a fruit shaped
exactly like my head just stop talking
you're ruining my concentration you're
fine
chill he's going to
die did you hear that what was that well
nothing we can do you guys want to grab
pizza what the heck are those things
they like little Shreks to
me we've prepared our whole lives for
this
oh my God oh my I'm goingo what happened
is Don
bleeding so you were baby turtles who
made contact with mystery goo well we
prefer the term ooo but yeah it's like
more like it's just Nic it rolls off the
tongue better yeah
o it's nice
[Music]
right
you're not here we're not there the car
exploded come get the girls I have to
stay here with woodro I'm not the
chauffer I'm the grandfather where are
you asteroid City farm Route 6 M
75 my junior star gazers and space cadet
each year we celebrate asteroid day
commemorating September 23rd 3 7 BC when
the Arid Plains meteorite made Earth
impact holy Toledo that's Mitch Campbell
you're very good in the one about the
[__] in the brothel who gets amnesia
and a pediatrician you were very aw
actually maybe my favorite character
I've ever SE I don't know why nobody
else liked it
oh what do those pulses indicate what oh
the beeps and blips we don't know some
of our information about outer space May
no longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an
alien what's happening now I don't know
I don't like the way that guy looked at
us the alien how did he how look like
we're doomed maybe we are I've just
informed the president how long can they
keep us an asteroid City legally the
world will never be the same that's an
alien doing Jeffy Jacks that's an alien
in a top hat what's out there the
meaning of life maybe there is one are
you married I'm a widower but don't tell
my kids you saying mother died 3 weeks
ago let's say she's in heaven which
doesn't exist for me of course but
you're Episcopalian in my loneliness I
learned to give complete and
unquestioning Faith to the people I love
I don't know if that includes you but it
included my daughter and your four
children sometimes I think I feel more
at home outside the Earth's atmosphere
oh wow me too they're strange aren't
they they're
children compared to normal people yes
that's correct it's true Fain train so
fast I do aene you want to see
[Music]
it huh did I say yes you didn't say
anything I meant yes my M my mouth
didn't
speak it's known as the beautiful game
but let's face it it's a complicated
game guys soccer as you like to call it
is like life next season I think we have
a real shot I'm sorry uh Thomas did
nobody tell you you're you're
fired good news is you got two options
option one that's where you're currently
at or American s are you
serious we haven't scored one goal in
the history of our country trying to
have a so team go let go again
humiliation mark my words things are
going to change I got as a new
coach something to drink whiskey beer
wine yep we got all those which one
whiskey beer and
wine it's safe to say you have zero
Talent OR understanding of the game
something not right about this guy well
he is
white Coach you got the toughest job on
the
island only one was just one goal one
goal come on guys we've worked too long
and hard for this you've only been here
a few
days what the I can't work with these
guys for them it's like some sort of
game it is a game
thas that's it Chia leadership now we're
making some
progress dear Lord thank you for sending
us Mr rongan we've become quite attached
to him it's like finding a little lost
white kid at the mall and telling him
which way to
go
holy I will tell you I've never seen
anything like it
holy is the craziest I think I've ever
seen everything
okay $1 million what are you going to do
get a Ferrari what the oh language the
baby's
here yo what up everybody Roan Kitty
here I'm going to pick a stock and talk
about why I think it's interesting and
that stock is GameStop oh this
guy retail Traders hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it looks like there's one guy
driving all the buying who is
this dumb money man happy to take
it W Street is betting that this company
is going to fail if it fails these hedge
funded people make a ton of
money 7,000 people have watched this
video Kitty I love
you if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
Game Stop Those shares not stopping let
stop it's only going to go up when they
hit I'm going to buy you a mansion let's
drink to that my brother is a nerd Wall
Street must be seeing this right you
should probably dial in holy [__] do you
have a minute I uh
um babe how much did we make today 5
million how much did we lose today a
billion and yesterday 4 million and
yesterday a billion
yeah we're like really
rich you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the GameStop
situation retail Traders always lose
you've been surfed Wall Street
Che surprise surprise you have to
testify before Congress the game has
changed it's us who you think win it's
what's the point winning the race if you
let some idiot steal the priz a lot of
people feel the system is broken the
whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune certainly
not
anymore there's no hope for the little
guy [__]
balls maybe now there is
[Music]
yeah
meet the residents of element
City Air usually has their head in the
cloud oh my new jacket Earth can be a
little
seedy nothing weird going on here uh
just a little
pruning water is always getting into
[Music]
something help and fire as ordered we
run a little
hot
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule elements cannot
mix what the that pipe squished me all
out of shape
dang that's better
oh so you've never left fire town sorry
buddy elements don't mix hey Plus my dad
would boil you alive why does anyone get
to tell you what you can do in your life
come
on why do they even have these eh who
knows watch
this
W Ember I see a change in
you what her guy you live here it's my
mom's place we got two kids that are
swimming around here somewhere Mar
follow I've been trying to fill my
father's shoes but I never once asked
what I wanted to
do try this Dad those are too hot I love
hot
[Music]
[Applause]
food you see he likes
[Music]
it I've been having the strangest
dreams Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century hi Rachel we're delighted to let
you know that we've had movement on our
weight
list we got a spot at the wom Center oh
my God but I haven't told Alie yet why
Rachel he wants a natural
child hold on you put us on a weight
list to have a baby in an egg no it's
not an egg it's it's an
egg women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their career and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you let's do it Rachel
really
yeah I'm sure you're all very excited
parents are raving about it it is the
ultra
solution my nephew was born at the womb
Center but he doesn't dream I wouldn't
worry about
it I can't I can't do it with a pot in
here what are you talking about it can't
see
us I feel Alvi is able to bond with our
child but I'm
not maybe I'm just not ready to be a
mother you know no one's a mother just
like that you become
one lately I've been holding on to
something we are considering having a
home birth I'm sorry it's not possible I
won't raise this child without
nature congratulations it's so exciting
isn't it
still I noticed a change in productivity
you do have a baby at the womb center
right why what's
[Music]
going things are revolving your family
Dynamics are about to undergo tremendous
changes how can we make sure our babies
not bored in utero oh yeah we don't want
any bored
babies
you know you really captured his
Essence maybe his face could use a
little more detail
though like a photograph I'm Adam Chloe
1 2
3 sure you not going to make fun of it
just show me all
right oh my
God this might be the nicest thing
anyone's ever done for
[Music]
me you have 62 View viewers and $300
total they don't have love in their
culture they find romantic stuff super
exotic and
interesting they watch you go on
dates family dinner is one of our most
cherished human rituals do you have to
do this right now Chloe you're not
supposed to talk about the broadcast on
the broadcast floting in
space hey would you keep that [__] out
of my line of sight why don't you keep
your [__] out of our line of sight you
didn't invent courtship broadcast
[__] it has recently become obvious you
are deceiving your viewers what
deceiving the title of your broadcast is
Adam and Chloe in love and yet you are
not in
love I want you to repay all funds you
have received wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live
then I will take you to court and your
families will be in debt for
approximately six
Generations do you want me to cut that
for
you where is the nearest
restaurant no part of my body can make
that noise it's well it certainly won't
if you don't
try we can get that love
back romantic love is the most poetic of
all human love modes it should never be
faked I'm just like any other person I
want to grow up and fall in love and be
swept off my
feet we've lost a lot since you guys
came
here but we've overcome a lot
[Music]
too ladies and gentlemen of the
jury how y'all doing for all of y'all
that don't know who I am my name it's
wiie Gary willly Gary Wily Gary William
Gary never heard of him what's so
special about this guy
anyway litigation is war it's a battle
bam and I'm not talking about no
[__] either I'm talking about some
Jean CLA vanam ass kicking [__] truth is
I may have got myself into a lot of
trouble I've been your lawyer 30 years
we can find a way out of it you've never
sued anybody before in your whole life
still TR to bully me out of business and
I don't think I should be expected to
stand for white Mr Gary hasn't lost a
case in over 12 years you suggesting I
hire this guy's one of my lawyers y'all
come on in pleasure to meet you Mr Gary
let me introduce you to my CED how do
you feel about working with black folk I
suppose I am a little Prejudice did you
meet my team I'm Chris Des Douglas
gentlemen he's suing us he's suing us we
are a half a billion dollar Corporation
so how much money y trying to get 8
million that ain't enough money $100
million who is this clown he's hired as
a
lawyer you fighter man what made you
want to do it cuz he tried to mess with
the one thing that means the most to me
in life being able to leave something
behind for my
grandchildren let's play some
music my name is main DS graduated top
of her class from Harvard Law School
they had a nickname for her around the
office the python I wouldn't get too
used to me being being kind to you Mr
Gary once we begin that
trial I will destroy
you we don't have a snowball's chance in
hell to winning this case just just
trust me okay I I I may have found
something what does it feel like to be
some small time nobody on the verge of
bankruptcy what if I don't win and I let
all these people down you have been
trying to turn this into your own one
ring circus I got my damn live on the
line I know that
Jerry did it ever bother you the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy you shut your
ass
down hey hey wait wait what's we can't
split the pole can't split the pole now
come
on now
[Music]
see yes hi I have some bad news we lost
your mom what sorry that was terrible
phrasing I meant we don't know where she
is oh I think your sister's here Annie
It's finally happened oh my God it's
okay it's okay I'm here we're oh my God
you're or any she's not dead she ran
away the [__] and yum your Mom owes me
80 grand when you have it you'll get
your dog back I don't have any money you
can sell your eggs it's not like you're
using them no there has to be another
way what is the square root of 196 14
correct how many hearts does an octopus
have correct what saffron Saturn
Aphrodite Apollo Aries carbon dioxide
the equal sign correct oh my God what
you know this game this is how you're
going to make the money I'm taking you
to the
quitt Le not a drive racist oh hi come
on it's going to be fun I'm not sleeping
on the floor I'm not sleeping on the
floor either I sleep on the chair I
don't want to sleep in a sitting
position oh my
God I can't play on live TV in front of
millions of people let you get to it and
know you got to get through hair and
makeup I already went through hair
makeup well and you missed a spot I
can't do this am I sing yeah you know
what put your arms down you're having a
panic attack doctors prescribe these is
that
cocaine oh Stevia do do you ever use
stevia the sweetener yeah yeah I've got
it in my
pocket win or lose we'll do it
together that is definitely broken I bet
you I could pop it back in my no I can't
I'm going to throw
[Music]
up how can I ever thank you maybe like a
drink later well I'm married and gay why
did you have to say two
reasons
[Music]
hi there uh big dogs I'm trying to get
home I know which way that is oh great
right up my you little oh no that can't
be right I'm lost you're astray now you
can do anything you want this beard
doesn't taste good but I like how it's
making me feel have you ever humped
anything before I recently this couch
best sex of my life and she dirty too oh
well I I can tell looks like she hasn't
been washed in years I see you later
baby it was nice to meet
you I really should find my way back
home we could
help we're completely lost and my little
puppy PW pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse huh how could it get
worse hold on
Buddy oh wow your balls look huge from
this angle thank you but
holy that is the craziest thing I have
ever seen and I'm Dennis Quaid and
Dennis Quid is seen some sh
I'm starving how many of these should we
eat all of them give me a second wa you
look different you look different too
how so is it my human
hands sit the cops oh God what do we do
calm down I got this hello officer none
of us shut the
up hey Doc mhm I was thinking tonight
could be a good night for sex night
possibly
oo it's an interesting idea but you know
Thursdays Steven LM how's the new Opera
coming along good great we had discuss
seeing a first draft of the score in two
weeks that still all right I'm suffering
from a temporary blockage at the
moment no turn it back on
one g
flat is he all right he had a total
break on after his last
St I can't do
this you need to take a walk jolt your
brain out of its little rad pattern
interact with a stranger okay honey I
have a patient
bye are we going that way I keep
imagining you naked I don't know if you
want to hear more details about these
images
no I bet every one of these people has a
story for an opera in them Levi what do
you do I operate a tugboat
wrong hands this tug is a deadly
weapon I'm addicted to romance isn't
everybody I've been arrested for
stalking I had to go to rehab and not
supposed to be doing
this can't believe that actually
happened I mean she seduced me right
she's a
witch the demented tugboat captain who
lurs men to her Tugboat and kills them
and eats them I loved it how did you
come up with
that I was really angry at you and now
it turns out I'm your amus you what oh
St I'll never leave you
um I love cleaning cling is as close to
Godliness my patients are talking I
imagine getting inside their heads with
disinfectant and just scrubbing them
down your tugboat captain came to see me
I'm in Love no no just admit that I had
a magic effect on you my imagination
came up with the story my talent wrote
the music I mean you don't kill men and
eat them do you well I haven't
yet you know I can't resist to romantic
story even if I'm not in
[Music]
it pressure's all right Gary it's
perfect is there any area in particular
you want me to focus on today um Gary
how many guys have you done this with
you're the first guy that I've ever been
intimate with I had a wife she left I
really don't know what to say I mean
words of affirmation is not my love
language it's more like
I've been alive for nearly half a
century and I haven't actually lived
even a second of it Gary I'm going to
help you let's find someone for you oh
my God there's so many ODOT guys I think
that this might just be too much too
late he's already on his way wait
what hello what Su bro just want to get
in and get out oh you can get in all
right it's a gorgeous Landing what are
you doing I'm calling 911 Gary no
accidents happened it was your first
time being gay did you really think you
we going to make any mistakes [__] he
bled through the tarp that's Mountain
Ashwood it's really porous oh my God
you're so
gay are you a cop no wait are you no
good cuz the dark web's built on trust
come
on is this what it's like this is what
it's like I am like human poppers I open
anyone up I'm really glad I met
you even if multiple people are dead
because of it dripping
Diamond Eyes
silent as we geter Church girls know how
to
kneel where are you
going I am a cool Hot Z where'd you kill
him oh we right outside you moov the
body in the closet you guys ever seen
gong girl aart with like stick
Gary
do you know what the greatest thing
about America is you can make things
happen here like nowhere
else you have the power to create your
own future you can be anything you can
do
anything you want to sell high-end
stuffed Himalayan cats under stuffed
actually for greater posability we're
professionals we're giving the people
what they
[Music]
need
did you see the latest numbers we broke
the entire internet
thing you go big or you go
home Ty would tell you he did it
all which is as crazy as believing
stuffed animals are
gold did you see the truck
crash
insane poor
beanies this has always been my company
company we created together why do you
have to be so dramatic I mean my salary
has been reduced 75% yeah I'm just doing
what's necessary you know running the
real actual business over
[Music]
here my life is this company I see where
it's
going there are signs of real trouble
genius is 1% inspiration
99%
presentation that's not how the S
goes everything good that that's
happened to me is because of you guys we
are bonded
forever have you considered poisoning
him countless
times I have our perfect Partners lined
up Jehovah's Witnesses the greatest
one-on-one salesman in the world how
brilliant is
[Music]
that I'm going to
go you're dead to
[Music]
me I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached
out how did you come to write this book
what really struck me was that too few
books were about my people where are our
stories where's our representation would
you give us the pleasure of reading an
excerpt yo Shira girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you Monk your books are good but they're
not popular editors they want a black
book they have a black book I'm black
and it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they publish look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses
it i' be standing outside in the night
dead beat dads rappers crack you said
you wanted black stuff that's black
right I see what you
doing we sold your book no we believe Mr
Lee has written the bestseller that's a
joke the most lucrative joke you've ever
told now is stag a pseudonym yeah Mr Lee
can't use his real name is this based on
your actual
life yeah you think some [__] ass
college boy can come up with that [__]
no no no I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that not me they ran
300,000 copies your books change
people's lives they're offering $4
million for moving rights yes the Dumber
I behave the Richer I
get this has gone too far stag arly is
still on the run from authorities you
haven't done anything it's not like they
can arrest
you it is wish I could go back to not
selling books is it bad to cater to
people's taste people want to love you
Monk you should let them love all of you
there's already so much Buzz because of
the movie deal Michael beat Jordan is
circling we want to put him on the cover
in one of those um scarves I guess you
would call all them tied around his head
a doag doag that's it doag and a tank
top with the muscles showing something
called a fire
[Music]
department we're thinking we can get it
out in time for
Te don't you let that dog piss on my
walkway he has no idea who's doing that
well it was one of
you
[Music]
hey Ado no don't you dare let that
little red dog piss on my walkway again
ignore him print he has no idea who's
doing that it was one of
you get out of here you cannot use this
road without a permit have a nice day
sir you know the other guys don't do
this the guys with the white trucks how
come it's always you brown guys and I
don't mean that
racially I'm sorry I didn't get him here
earlier the whole neighborhood is
falling apart these
[Music]
days no no no no no stop oh my God give
me the keys hello hello what's your name
Otto Oto OT t o I'm Abby OT t
o got some new neighbors bye thatw
husband I brought you some food okay bye
are you always this unfriendly I am not
unfriendly okay you're not every word
you say is like a warm
cuddle
hi can you please give me a ride I don't
have a license you don't have a driver's
license how old are you puning and
breaking break the car is stopped hit
the car break break I almost hit the car
that's all right it's a hybrid it's all
right how did you get in here go no no
no you are not taking over my
bed I was wondering if you could help us
out I'm not sure about this it's going
to be very
fun how was it you did a good job you
should pat yourself on the
[Music]
back I have a
cat you think you have to do everything
on your own but guess what no one
can
sh all right I'm PE hi you want to see a
trick could I borrow a coin what did you
do back the
corner it was all the Clown's
[Music]
fault a lot has happened since My Big
Fat Greek
Wedding my father passed away and His
Last Wish was for us to visit his
childhood Village and reconnect with our
roots so we're having a reunion we're
cour to Greece oh yeah 1 2
3 and by we I
mean the whole family who wants sui
paging sui anybody by the name of suaki
on this
flight Aristotle what I didn't know you
were going to be here what are you doing
here they had an amazing date she
ghosted
him
you are the pual family we are related
through your Pap Pap who was married to
my great great Yaya
sister I want bua I will be your
favorite I promise my dad I would find
his best friends I know them do they
still live here no how do we find them
they will come for the reunion did they
tell you they're coming
no there's no other bedrooms family
sleep over this is one reunion
we'll never forget do you know these men
no I am surprised but I am not surprised
because I'm never
surprised you lost me
[Music]
everybody we Dam about Aristotle last
night how did you know Greek Voodoo
bam I really need to find my dad's
friends Angelo and I are on it okay bye
[Music]
I'm calling it you got us back to
Grease You're the head of the family now
much can't really D drink like don't
worry a lady is never
drunk pick the one we have for dinner oh
thank you uh I'm a
vegetarian
no
we got
these everybody listen this is important
I'm going to show you guys something and
when I show you what I'm going to show
you don't freak
out I can
[Music]
explain It's Beginning to Look a Lot
Like Christmas high stakes as neighbors
compete for best decorated house on the
Block I think this is the house to beat
wow what's your Christmas
wish I just want to win this
[Music]
thing I'll take
it signature please ignore all the fine
print it's like you're signing your life
away Merry Christmas yeah Merry
Christmas oh it will
[Laughter]
be rise and shine Naughty
Boy what the hell is all of this
something's happening good morning sir
are you real we all were until we fell
into that El's sck
trap you made your wish you're in it now
I didn't sign on for this you literally
signed on for this you got to read the
fine print man the terms of service are
brutal say goodbye to your
dad why y'all just like
Prince we are not going to let her turn
your Dad into one of those weird Happy
Meal toys no offense I'm sorry none
taken a little
taken we are the
Carvers we got to catch an
elf you met with the wrong
family we should split up what do you
mean we should split up have you never
watched a horror film if you split up
somebody dies have you ever died oh it
is not fun that's true I've never died
but Mom knows I didn't know you die
before let's find
[Music]
green is that who I think it is oh my
God black S I knew SLE with black
[Music]
man they spent what a trillion dollars
trying to get one dude back from Mars if
you get the opportunity to bring back
Matt Damon I just don't think we should
wait around to be saved you know you
really don't think they're sending
anybody to save us I mean
[Music]
[Applause]
in case you haven't noticed we're doomed
to spend the rest of our miserable lives
on this ship maybe we should do it do
what
it we're not attracted now but we would
emotionally attached you mean fall in
love what if this awesome thing we have
going on gets ruined people are meant to
be together oh sorry is this is this on
okay
lame
we're both married I'm sure being a
drift in space gives you a h
[Music]
pass you know what you want to watch
tonight alien never seen
it why the hell did we watch that
movie oh was class sorry that was my
fault are you okay you just had Zach
McLaren's ball in your face M what's his
GPA you have any books on battle toads
you know video games are now the leading
cause to divorce Could you actually
order me a book on that really no
sarcasm is frequently an attempt to
deflect one's ignorance so being to know
it all oh wait you forgot your credit
card
hey oh my God what's up heck get a car
now he's a concussion and think at him
his girlfriend thank God it's you oh oh
all righty he is dating his Zoe what
other Zoe he's he either dead or he's
dumbed me honestly I'm not sure which is
worse make sure Zach takes it easy his
symptoms could get worse what do I do
you don't want him getting worse pretend
to be the other Zoe you've been dating 2
or 3 weeks now
right
y this is z cousin miles he's in grad
school at MIT oh my God a match for Zoe
I caused the accident and now I'm going
to flirt with an Amnesia patient's
cousin we're all going to go skiing in
the mountains this weekend you want to
go with us strip of land seven letters m
christm how did you know that well done
you two should we H slums yeah we
shall it's confusing I'm enjoying
getting to know you over again go you a
swing up
life you and Zach do you really think
it's you're a good match like we are
it's
complicated
J we need to tell him the truth you have
to go after what you want and be
Brave oh my God you're just giving me
romcom advice now no it's so
[Music]
fun so what did you do did you have fun
what didn't we do excuse me All PG-13
[Music]
okay
a